es geht um das recht von staatsbürger
ändern ihre religionsfreiheit ausleben
zu dürfen in dem moment wenn sie doch
kann ich nicht wo nicht alles wissen nur
nicht als lehrer die nur nicht als
richter den zirkel als kassiererin als
erzieherin im wofür soll ich noch
arbeiten
[Musik]
13 fragen hier kommt frage nummer eins
sollen religiöse symbole in öffentlichen
einrichtungen verboten werden ja oder
nein wenn ihr sagt ja religion muss
privatsache bleiben dann bitte auf dem
grünfeld positionieren und wenn ihr sagt
nee nee im moment wir haben in
deutschland religionsfreiheit dann bitte
auf dem gelben feld und biss
[Musik]
vielen dank jetzt wissen wir wo er steht
aber wo steht ihr kopftuch kreuz oder
kipper haben in öffentlichen
einrichtungen nichts verloren sagen die
einen denn religion muss privatsache
bleiben das gilt für schule gerichtssäle
oder auch für die polizei ja moment
sagen die anderen in deutschland
herrscht ja aus gutem grund
religionsfreiheit verbote würden diese
einschränkungen zu dem die gläubigen
diskriminieren zum beispiel am
arbeitsplatz
solche fälle landen in letzter zeit
immer häufiger vor höchsten gerichten
zuletzt beim europäischen gerichtshof
das zeigt zwei dinge erstens die sache
ist juristisch gesehen verdammt knifflig
und zweitens diese gesellschaft ist sich
ganz offenbar uneins wie sie mit
religion in der öffentlichkeit umgehen
will
uneins sind sich heute auch meine gäste
aber bei 310 fragen geht es ja um den
kompromiss der ist bei dieser frage
bisschen schwierig und trotzdem habe ich
die hoffnung dass wir trotzdem zeigen
können die wir vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr aufeinander zugehen können ob das
heute klappt schauen wir mal aber
erstmal die frage natürlich an euch wo
würde die euch positionieren auf der
grünen seite religion muss privatsache
bleiben oder auf der gelben nein
religionsfreiheit muss durchgesetzt
werden die regeln sind ganz einfach wenn
ihr der gegenseite in irgendeinem punkt
zustimmt dann dürft ihr gerne einen
schritt nach vorne kommen das heißt auf
die gegenseite zu gehen und wenn ihr
sagt eigentlich finde ich deine meinung
gar nicht so schlecht aber da erzählst
du gerade großen mist dann könnt ihr
auch ein schritt zurück gehen also euch
entfernen von der gegenseite mein ziel
ist es natürlich möglichst nahe in die
mitte zu bringen hier in dieses so
genannte kompromiss fällt mal sehen ob
das dann am ende dieser folge auch
klappt 13 fragen hier kommt frage 2 und
die geht an rabia du studierst jura du
bist gläubige muslima und du hast sorge
dass auch was deinen beruf anbelangt
dann kopftuch ein problem in
anführungszeichen werden könnte nämlich
in liefern anfang mai wurde ein gesetz
beschlossen das neue beamtin ein gesetz
das dazu verleiten könnte das jetzt mehr
beamtenstatus verwehrt wird wir haben
jetzt einfach 20 20 die entscheidung
gehabt von einer rechtsreferendarin aus
hessen der bestimmte bereiche im
referendariat wenn sie halt auf der
richterbank sitzen würde oder bei der
staatsanwaltschaft aufgabe übernehmen
dass sie gefahr bestünde dass da eine
gefahr für die neutralität der justiz
wäre und auch da sehen wir das argument
ja der vor gericht wüsste man ja nicht
der objekt der verfahrensbeteiligte ob
die richterin jetzt nach der
rechtsordnung urteil würde oder dass sie
nicht neutral ist religiöse symbole sind
für mich kein von identität ich finde es
sehr wichtig dass wir die identitäten
unserer mitbürger erinnern sehen kann
gerade dann wenn diese identitäten durch
unser grundgesetz geschützt sind ich
würde gerne wissen warum wir in diesen
20 jahren durch gerichtsentscheidungen
versuchen wege zu finden wie wir das
kopftuch einschränken oder gar verbieten
kann und dadurch frauen vom arbeitsmarkt
halten könnt ihr nachvollziehen rabia
ist angst dass gesagt moment mal ich
also ich bin ja nur man gläubig das ist
nun mal so dass sie dann angst hat quasi
eine art berufsverbot auferlegt zu
bekommen ich kann das verstehen und das
wird auch ein punkt sein bei dem ich
früher oder später mich zumindest
vorsichtig in das nächste feld vage weil
ich mir gut vorstellen kann wie es sich
anfühlt als anhängerin einer religion
von bestimmten berufen ausgeschlossen zu
werden in einem land in dem kirchen
profiliert werden das ist nämlich das
eigentliche problem und deswegen mache
ich jetzt einfach schon mal diesen
schritt und sage ich bin total bei dir
wenn du nicht verstehst warum in bezug
auf den islam der eine religion
staatliche neutralität gefordert wird
wohingegen die kirchen aus steuergeldern
subventioniert werden also nicht nur aus
der kirchensteuer bei weitem nicht die
kirchen eigene gesetze haben und
beispielsweise was das arbeitsrecht
angeht da sollten perfekt treffen der
bereich und diese kirchen von vorne bis
hinten mit der politik in bester
lobbyarbeit zusammenarbeiten ich finde
dass religiöse symbole an staatlichen
institutionen deswegen nichts verloren
haben weil der staat seiner pflicht zur
neutralität zur weltanschaulichen
neutralität nachkommen muss und er es
eigentlich so etwas wie ein
unparteiischer schiedsrichter auf dem
markt der welt anschauen und es ist ja
richtig da eine religionsfreiheit wird
tatsächlich ein kleines stückchen
eingeschränkt aber ich denke das ist
zumutbar denn jedes freiheitsrecht endet
dort wo die freiheiten anderer beginnen
und rechte müssen immer miteinander
abgewogen werden und ich bin ganz fest
der überzeugung dass das
staatliche neutralitätsgebot
schwerer wiegt als dein religiös
motivierter wunsch auch während der
arbeit als richterin mehreren oder
polizistin ein kopftuch zu tragen also
erstens glaube ich also erstmal danke
für deine offenheit und zweitens
also a wird ihre religiöse freiheit
nicht ein kleines bisschen beschränkt
und es ziemlich ein massiver eingriff
und die zweite frage ist ja auch noch
warum eigentlich was gibt es für eine
massive begründung
etwas so stark einzuschränken wo weder
gefahr droht noch eine manipulation im
raume steht ein verbot von religiösen
symbolen
an staatlichen organisationen und
staatlichen institutionen muss deswegen
diskutiert werden weil es ist eine frage
der grundrechte es ist gleichzeitig auch
eine frage dessen in welchem klima wir
leben wollen ich fasse das mal kurz
zusammen wer aber jetzt mal angenommen
sie wollte richterin wäre sie könnte die
neutral zur objektivste beste richterin
aller zeiten sein darf aber ihren beruf
vielleicht nicht ausüben weil sie eben
gläubig ist doch darf sie also ist denn
wirklich die religionsfreiheit
eingeschränkt es ist doch das symbol das
sagen jetzt ganz ehrlich das kopftuch
ist es doch was das eigentliche symbol
ist was als religion symbol nicht
gezeigt werden soll sollen keine
religion symbole gezeigt dass das kreuz
auch nicht bei mir in der schule
beispielsweise und auch nicht die kippe
nun ist für mich die frage ist denn das
das einzige zeichen der eine religion
nach außen zu zeigen
ich kenne sicherlich auch gläubige
frauen die kein kopftuch tragen und
trotzdem den glauben haben also den
menschen die darauf bestehen religiöse
symbole der öffentlichen im öffentlichen
raum der schule zu zeigen
muss ich entgegnen dass die schule dafür
nicht den raum bieten kann sondern wir
sind wirklich ein neutraler ort und
religiöse symbole und auch das werben um
religion gehört nicht in den raum in den
öffentlichen raum einer schule so und
die frage ist ob die das tragen des
kopftuchs es durch artikel 4 geschützt
und jetzt zu sagen wir haben muslime
denn sie tragen das nicht aber wir haben
noch andere muslime die tragen und die
die es tragen pustekuchen dürfte in dem
bereich nicht arbeiten und es geht gar
nicht darum dass ich mir nicht neutral
handel es geht um die zuschreibung meine
handlung und das finde ich schwierig
wenn wir das nämlich durchgehen lassen
dass aufgrund der zuschreibung menschen
beruf nicht mehr ausüben dürfen und ein
gesetz zu erlassen werden da werden wir
in anderen bereichen gerade auch in der
justiz oder verwaltung gehörige probleme
bekommen aber dann als argument war ja
es gibt keinen anfangsverdacht warum
sollte ich dann überhaupt wenn jemand
ein religiöses bekenntnis in die
öffentlichkeit trägt davon ausgehen dass
er eventuell nicht neutral sein könnten
aber ich gehe gar nicht davon aus dass
wir nicht neutral ist ich gehe davon aus
dass die person de also wenn wir jetzt
vor gericht sind oder wenn wir in der
schule sind dass es eher den
schutzbedürftigsten dass es denen er
erschwert wird gerade mädchen und frauen
die vielleicht aus fundamentalistischen
familien kommen gemeinschaften kommen
wie sollen dies raus schaffen wenn sie
überall religiöse symbole sehen die
trennung zwischen religion und staat ist
insbesondere wichtig für
lgs mädchen und frauen die entweder auf
dem weg sind sich aus einer
fundamentalistischen
familie struktur zu befreien oder das
schon geschafft haben und sich
in einem neutralen staat vertreten
fühlen können also wir überlegen die
evangelikalen werden in deutschland
immer größer eigentlich in bayern hängen
an schulen kruzifixe also wie ist das
für eine person obwohl bayern ist
katholisch aber wie ist das eine person
die es eigentlich daraus schaffen will
immer wieder diese symbole zu sehen und
fragen wir doch mal den mann der das
kreuz steht und auch gerne das kreuz in
öffentlichen räumen hat richtig ja doch
genau ich freue mich zu über also ohne
ersten beiden ist nicht cartoon
südlich vielleicht franken jetzt er
kommt aus irland existiert nicht zu
bayern so richtig genau ist es natürlich
aber auch da also ich kann das nicht
ganz nachvollziehen weil das so viele du
sagst sie kann ja ein teilbereich von
dem was ihr ohne kopftuch möglich wäre
trotzdem machen aber halt nicht alles
und ich fühle mich da an die ddr
erinnert womit viele christinnen
erzählen ich durfte studieren ich dort
kann er dann nennt man wahrlich was nach
außen getragen habe sondern weil sie
wussten dass sich damals in die kirche
gehen und um kirchenvorstand bin und
davor warne ich war also warum sollte
man das eingrenzen warum kommt diese
vermutung dass jemand der ja nicht weil
er jemanden irgendwie übernehmen will
ein religiöses symbol trägt sondern weiß
halt zu ihm gehört religiöse symbole
sollten den staatlichen institutionen
nicht verboten werden gerade nicht im
persönlichen bereich denn es macht den
menschen als ganzes aus nicht nur das
wir scheinen und das was er tut sondern
auch die spirituelle geistliche seite
das was er glaubt naja aber fakt das
argument war ja sie redet ja nicht über
dich als person sondern über diejenigen
die sich damit auseinandersetzen müssen
dass du zum beispiel triesen kreuzung
als tricks beispielsweise und sie sagt
dir werden eventuell gibt es neun
gruppen dieser vielleicht immer wieder
neu traumatisiert werden weil sie zum
beispiel aus fundamentalen gründen
kommen denen würde man das leben
leichter machen also das ist ja eine
güterabwägung zwischen deyn seinen
rechten und den rechten der leute die
sich vielleicht jetzt kommt fühlen darum
kreuz also ich bin schritt vorgegangen
weil ich das schon nicht uninteressant
fand und weil ich das auch
nachvollziehen kann weil es tatsächlich
auch so ist dass die implizierte
problematik mit starken religiösen
symbolen natürlich auch vor der
orthodoxen seiner fundamentalistischen
seite her kenne auch im judentum es gibt
natürlich eine extreme beengung und der
eingrenzung von freiheiten in familien
von frauen reichten von jede menge
sachen die einhergehend mit einer
religiösen symbolik das ist richtig und
trotzdem ist es natürlich unverschämt er
sagt ja du kannst du einen anderen beruf
wählen wäre doch irgendwie ein von der
nichtstaatlichen welt ich muss ja nicht
richterin werden was sich wenn sie
richterin werden will weil das ihr traum
ist das ist doch niemand das recht
jedoch grund dessen zu sagen wie sie
sich verhalten muss und wie gesagt was
steht dem entgegen was ist denn
überhaupt ein problem das ganze mal ein
kopftuch trägt das würde ich gerne
direkt beantworten du hast vorhin vor
dem anfangsverdacht gesprochen dieser
anfangsverdacht gilt nicht den trägern
und trägerinnen der religiösen symbole
sondern sie gilt der religion und die
ist extrem gut begründbar du sprichst
von der ddr da reden wir von den letzten
50 60 jahren wir können uns die
vorherigen jahrhunderte anschauen was
mit menschen gemacht wurden die sich
nicht zum christentum bekannt haben wir
können heute in islamisch regierte
länder schauen und uns anschauen was mit
menschen gemacht wird die sich nicht zum
islam und seinen werten bekennen die
werden gesteinigt werden öffentlich
geköpft das war im christentum lange
zeit nichts anderes das orthodoxe
judentum erfüllt das genauso und hier
ist der anfangsverdacht ex also der ist
nicht nur ein anfangsverdacht sondern es
ist lässt sich ganz klar zeigen dass das
heutige bildungssystem und rechtssystem
davon sprechen wir heute nur deswegen so
gut funktioniert und uns eine freie und
offene gesellschaft beschert weil wir
uns in jahrhunderten von der religion
emanzipiert haben und heute exakt diese
symbole wieder genau da rein zu holen
wäre kontraproduktiv und deswegen ich
hoffe wieder einen schritt näher so wenn
man deine deine argumentation jetzt
konsequent weiterverfolgt dann bist du
ja nicht dagegen dass religiöse symbole
in der öffentlichkeit gezeigt werden
sondern du bist gegen religionen an sich
nein ich halte religion für eine in dem
fall vollkommen unproblematische
privatsache wo religiöse menschen eben
keine übergriffigen
tätigkeiten ausüben die andere in ihren
rechten einschränken aber ich halte es
für schwer problematisch religiöse
überzeugungen in
liberal rechtsstaatliche systeme
einzuführen damit aus der clash damit
hast du es zumindest geschafft dass hier
bewegung auf dem spielfeld war die gab
es vorher auch schon bei carina nämlich
das habe ich vorhin aus dem augenwinkel
schon gesehen du bist auch nach vorne
gegangen als dani gerade gesprochen dann
nehme ich warum ich bin sehr für
gegenseitige toleranz für ich bin
ehrlich gesagt wirklich auch für
neutralität und ich bin ich komme aus
dem bereich schule und ich finde die
jünger die kinder sind umso deutlicher
muss der erwachsene der vor ihnen steht
neutral und offen sein und wenn man da
ganz deutlich mit einem kopftuch ist
dann ist man nicht neutral nach außen
ist manche erst mal nicht neutral ich
würde nicht werten nicht verurteilen
aber es ist einfach nicht neutrale und
wenn er mitglied der cdu es ist auch
nicht neutral oder von der
albert einstein
schule neutralität ist doch ein
absolutes illusion von liechtenstein das
gibt es nun einfach mal versuchen aber
nicht zu fahren ist der unterschied
natürlich es darf sich niemand
hinstellen und sagen guten tag ich bin
hier von der cdu ich bin heuer lehrern
oder
tragen cdu tisch ist aber was ist wenn
ich als lehrer und fischer tragen möchte
gegen nazis es geht ja nicht was die
säkularität sondern auch im
weltanschaulichen neutralität als es
gibt ja auch lehrer die
atomkraft nein danke die shirts tragen
oder scheiß nazis tücher tragen und ich
finde das gehört genauso wenig in die
schule natürlich ist irgendwie
neutralität irgendwie ein hirngespinst
also wir können nicht gänzlich
neutral sein wir sind immer noch
immer noch individuell zeigen es geht
mir gut es geht ums zeigen wege zu ihm
darum sich wenigstens zu bemühen
neutralität darzustellen also keine
symbole zu tragen aber rabia kannst du
das nachvollziehen jetzt hat man gerade
gesagt wenigstens das bemühen um
neutralität sollte durchaus auch
sichtbar sein ich kann den wunsch
verstehen aber letztendlich die
konsequenz von diesem reinen bemühen
während der verzicht auf mein recht das
tragen des kopftuchs ist sich artikel 4
geschützt dann kommt und das geht und so
bald wie ihr denn so eine staatliche
institution
neutralität propagieren aber dadurch
lockte ausschließen
dann sind wir nicht mehr neutral ich
finde staatliche institutionen müssten
gerade die vielfalt der bevölkerung
widerspiegeln dass wir von diesem
gesellschaftlichen diskurs haben dadurch
ermöglichen wir ja dass das wir heute
ein miteinander schwer kämpfen anders
geht es darum welche und wie sollen wir
dann funktionieren wenn wir einander
ausschließen selbst wenn man im regen
gericht dann das problem hätte okay die
richterin der richter wird befangen kann
ich ein befangenheitsantrag stellen und
ich fühle mich vermisst in der debatte
dass wir auf diese rechts instruments
liebe schon haben das finde ich darauf
verweisen und die bestärken weil dadurch
indem wir sind nicht betont dass wir den
mofas antrag habe bestraft hat mir schon
der rechtsbeugung können wir unser
system aus aber ich werde aber in diesem
instrument einfach schwächer ich bin vor
allem deswegen den ganz großen schritt
nach vorne gegangen und hab mich jetzt
auch noch weiteren dieses richtigen
kompromiss feld bewegt weil mir sehr
deutlich ausfällt desto die ganze zeit
ganz weit hinten an der ursprungs linie
steht vielleicht ist das nicht meine
absicht aber ich habe ein bisschen den
eindruck und das ist leider der eindruck
den ich öfter habe wenn ich mit
vertreterinnen und vertreter von
religion diskutieren dass die
kompromissbereitschaft relativ gering
ist so und das stört mich ich verstehe
dass du dich als muslima die sich dazu
verpflichtet fühlt ein kopftuch zu
tragen auch während der arbeit
ausgegrenzt und diskriminiert fühlte ich
würde fast sagen es tut mir leid wenn
ich diesen militärischen begriff hier an
bringe das ist seine art
kollateralschaden um dem staat vor dem
zugriff durch die religion zu schützen
und das denke ich müssen wir in kauf
nehmen wenn wir diese offene freie
gesellschaft schützen wollen da hab ich
ein kompromissvorschlag machen jetzt
schon ja gerne so wenn wir sagen würden
dass wir einen säkularen staat haben der
sich verpflichtet zu jeder religion
gleich fremd zu sein
bin ich noch weiter konzentrieren zum
aktuellen weil das ist unser staat ist
was ist die konsequenz aus einem
kompromiss fächer du bist jetzt nach
vorne gegangen aber ich hab das jetzt
also was was folgt daraus es folgt
daraus dass für die priester gefunden
haben auf die wir uns bei einigen kann
okay das heißt aber noch lange heißt er
hat jetzt nichts mit dir und dem
kopftuch im gerichtssaal zu tun ich
bleibe
jetzt carina vielleicht kannst du noch
mal kurz auf den punkt bringen warum
dürfen an deiner schule lehrer und
lehrerinnen keine religiösen symbole
öffentlich tragen also ich habe sehr
junge kinder und die werden eingeschult
beim eda sind sie fünf sechs jahre und
wir alle wissen je kleiner die kinder
sind umso stärker sind sie zu
beeinflussen und natürlich ist jeder
lehrer jede lehrkraft der erzieher jede
erzieherin bei mir ist für die kinder
auch ein vorbild und
ich möchte eben auch verhindern dass das
kinder klare religiöse symbole vor augen
haben und denken so muss das sein das
oder so muss das sein sie sollen bei mir
an der schule die möglichkeit haben sich
wirklich frei zu entfalten sie müssen
die möglichkeit haben bei mir so
gebildet so erzogen zu werden dass sie
eine ganz klare ganz klare meinungen
entwickeln ganz klare standings
selbstbewusste junge menschen werden die
sich dann selbst eine religion zu ordnen
oder eben auch nicht was befürchtet du
wenn jetzt wenn du jetzt quasi das
verbot kippst und sagst kommt macht was
ihr wollt zieht an was ihr wollt fragt
kreuze oder kopftücher oder gips was
würde dann passieren glaubt da gibt es
mehrere dinge die ich befürchte zum
einen befürchte ich wenn die die
lehrerin die wir an geliebt dann sagt
ein kleines mädchen zu seiner mutti zu
hause warum trägst du dann kein kopftuch
sondern muss die mutter sich zu hause
erklären und das in praxisbeispiele ich
möchte den eltern diese diskussion nicht
zumuten und ich möchte die diskussion in
der schule auch nicht haben ich möchte
aber auch nicht die diskussion haben
wenn nicht zum beispiel eine kollegin
mit einem kopftuch oder einen kollegen
mit einer kippa oder einen kreuzer dass
eltern zu mir sagen ich möchte aber dass
mein kind jetzt nur noch von der
lehrerin mit dem kopftuch oder gar nicht
schon der lehrerin mit dem kopftuch
unterrichten
das klingt doch alles ganz plausibel und
nachvollziehbar warum kommst du nicht
dass es nicht als ich bin jetzt wieder
zurückgegangen weil dessen schwierigen
freiheitsbegriff sender natürlich muss
man diese diskussion führen und ich
freue mich wenn seine schule geführt
dafür aber warum sollten wir da alles
ausklammern was menschen zu tief aus
zutiefst aus machst und natürlich durfte
das dann sein weil man lernt doch von
haltungen und wenn diese person ein
religiöses symbol trägt und sich
verfassungskonform verhalten dann ist es
doch perfekt und ich du hast vorhin
gesagt du wenn religiöse menschen immer
so wenig kompromissbereit aber die
vorannahmen die ich da jetzt gehört habt
die lasten der griechen dicken hals ich
höre überflüssig als ob als ob im
kopftuch oder ein kreuz sofort
übergriffig ist mensch kann
übergewichtig seien worte können
übergriffig sein sondern es steht das
trägt symbolhaft ihn zu tief ausmacht
und es auch plausibel erklärt der zum
beispiel auch erklärt warum ein kopftuch
trägt weil die kreuze hängen hat das
hilft doch kindern daran zu lernen er
aber man muss sicherlich auch das von
schule zu schule betrachten meine schule
seine schule wo wir 49 verschiedene
nationen haben da kommen menschen aus
kriegsgebieten die in diesem
kriegsgebiet feind waren und ich finde
dann haben wir als schule die aufgabe
denen auch einen neutralen einen
sicheren raum zu schaffen wo sie ohne
die ängste die sie in dem gebiet aus
denen sie geflüchtet sind zu uns
geflüchtet sind um hier sicher und ruhig
wohnen zu können da brauchen sie diesen
geschützten raum um zu lernen und es ist
meine aufgabe meine aufgabe als
schulleiter so einen ganz sicheren ganz
geschützten raum zu schaffen in dem die
kinder sich frei entfalten können und
jeden fall kann ich das nachvollziehen
und doch wieder denke ich doch dann hier
die kinder einen lehrer begegnen der
dieselbe regierung religion hat wie die
person die sie verfolgt hat die dafür
krieg ist sollte und die märkte und die
hat nicht aber liebt die behandeln mich
mit respekt die ermöglicht mir diese
lernräume und für mich nicht anhand
meiner nation beurteilen das ist doch
ein heilungsprozess also so dass ich mal
vor ich glaube diese vielfalt in den
schul deswegen gehe ich noch mal einen
schritt zu auf euch zu rudi ist mir
wichtig dies mir überall wichtig ich
finde wir leben in einer vielfältigen
gesellschaft die durch den staat auch
repräsentiert werden muss nur kann das
nur geschehen wenn jede religion
gleichwertig ist und wenn wir nicht nur
bei den drei weltreligionen
bleiben sondern bei jeder religion und
und das kann nur der staat vertreten
wenn er neutral bleibt und das ist so
mein punkt du kannst vielfalt nicht
darstellen wenn du so symbolfiguren
aufstellt wenn du symbole an den schulen
aufstellt sondern du kannst es nur über
neutralität die diese vielfalt erst
ermöglich da nicht ganz nachvollziehen
du stehst der relativ mittig ich habe
mich nach vorne gestellt weil carina das
thema sicherheit dass der emotionale
sicherheit und schülern
ins spiel gebracht hat das war ein punkt
der mir einfach ein geleuchtet hat das
ist tatsächlich etwas was sie mir nicht
überlegt habe und wo ich auch denke das
muss auch in arm mit es muss auch
gezogen wir als man müsste auch
natürlich auch das sehr wach beobachten
wenn man ein lehrer mit gefahr auf auf
kinder lässt die palästinensisch sind
die vielleicht ganz schlechte
erfahrungen mit
israelis oder wie auch immer gemacht
haben dann müsste man das irgendwie aber
es ist eben thema ich möchte nicht dass
herr lehrer seinen keeper aussehen
möchte sondern ich möchte dass man das
an der schule dann thematisiert und dass
man dann auch wirklich darüber streitet
und dass man auch spürt dass diese wand
abgebaut werden soll auf dieser bühne
der schule ist die beste möglichkeit die
kontraste und konflikte und die
unterschiedlichkeiten auch die regeln
religiösen unterschiedlichkeiten voll
auszuleben voll zu diskutieren deswegen
bin ich auch echt gegen der neutralität
ich bin der meinung ich finde ich
wünsche mir die haltung haben die auch
eine haltung vertreten ich wünsche mir
lehrer die schüler fordern auch mit
einer haben mit einer meinung die
vielleicht auch nicht alle haben ich
habe überhaupt nichts dagegen ich möchte
ich möchte dass wir die kinder
frühzeitig erziehen das leben ist
debatte das leben ist auch ein stück
weit eben auch nicht einig seien
kompromisse finden müssen gemeinsam
leben müssen auch wenn wir ganz ganz
unterschiedliche meinung haben aber das
ist eben nicht gelernt durch verbote er
muss eine zwischenfrage stellen an euch
was glaubt ihr gibt es so etwas wie
neutralität was versteht ihr darunter
und glaubt ihr menschen ohne öffentlich
getragene religiöse symbole sind
neutraler als die anderen was ist eure
meinung schreibt gerne in die kommentare
seien und jetzt von ich komme aus einer
kurdischen familie die eigentlich
atheistisch ist
das war mir lange nicht bewusst mir
wurde der vor mir wurde das geheim
gehalten weil es innerhalb der community
ein riesiges problem gewesen wäre wenn
ich es ausgeplaudert hatte ich glaube
die schwierigkeit die da ist man muss
halt auch an die minderheiten innerhalb
der minderheiten denken
man darf nicht irgendwie immer alles als
ein großes kollektiv betrachten ich bin
als kurde von nicht nur deutschen
rassisten sondern oft auch von
türkischen rassistin betroffen also ich
glaube dass eigentlich in der schule ein
schutzraum für alle mädchen frauen elche
pittis haben will die fern von also die
wirklich kein kreuz angucken müssen und
ihre sünden denken müssen wenn sie
irgendwie gerade mit den gedanken an den
süßen jungen an dem sie gerade irgendwie
sechste klasse denken noch oft an süße
jung
ich möchte nicht dass das dieser
schutzraum für die schutzbedürftigen
nicht vorhanden ist und die sind mir in
dieser diskussion die wichtigsten also
dreht ist eigentlich über negative
religionsfreiheit aber auch von leuten
die vielleicht tatsächlich religiös sind
katholisch erzogen wurden ein nicht
franken in bayern
aber trotzdem irgendwie ein schwules
begehren haben und jedes mal wenn sie in
der schule sind dieses kreuz betrachten
müssen und davon sich irgendwie immer
wieder bedroht fühlen also ich sehe dann
punkt auch total gerade wenn man das
geschichtlich betrachtet aber ich finds
guard gut ist ein kreuz präsentes um
ebenso eine fehlwahrnehmung die voll auf
tatsachen fuß die passiert sind die
menschen gemacht haben absolut vom kreuz
dass man dazu überreden das kreuz ist
nicht du bist denn du bist schlecht
seines kreuz ist jesus sein egal wer du
bist ob du bist ob du unternehmer bist
der du auch bist du bist gleich geliebt
in meinen augen und genau das möchte ich
das meditieren weil es in deutschland
halt sonst auch thema ist und dann
traurig schülern zu das hat er auch sich
dazu verhalten können ich als lehrer es
denen ermögliche das ist deine version
des christentums wie du sie und heute im
wahrscheinlich weitgehend aufgeklärten
oberfranken vom protestantismus her
wahrnimmst schauen wir aber an die
quelltexte der religionen schauen wir in
die gelebte religion und da will ich
keine unterschiede machen dann sieht das
ganz anders aus schule ist ein ort der
erkenntnis und nicht das bekenntnis
schule ist ein ort der aufklärung und
nicht der verklärung und natürlich muss
in der schule über religion gesprochen
werden und zwar massiv wäre region nicht
versteht versteht die tagesschau nicht
ich finde es super dass wir hier darüber
streiten und dass wir uns wieder
aufeinander zubewegen
denn die streitkultur ist gerade in den
religionen offensichtlich sehr schlecht
ausgeprägt wenn gerade diese verdacht
zeitung ist übergriffig wenn ich sage ja
du trägst das oder du bist das ziemlich
hoher prozentsatz bist du deswegen
überglücklich oder versucht dem kind
etwas auszudrücken was ist gar nicht
selber will es geht um symbole es geht
nicht um individuen also wenn du der
ansicht dass das jesus schwule
akzeptiert trans personen akzeptiert
dann glaube ich dir das aber das symbol
tut es für viele nicht und ich glaube
das ist ja der punkt also wir sprechen
hier über symbole wenn jemand der nicht
religiöses und der auch tatsächlich auch
sehr sehr wachsam und auch sehr
alarmiert beobachtet wie stark die macht
der religion ist und wie verantwortlich
auch fundamentalistische religion ist
seit es die welt gibt für sehr sehr
viele kriege und sehr viele konflikte
die aus religions- gründen geführt werde
in vielerlei hinsicht habe ich oft das
gefühl dass wir durch das dass wir in
einer zeit leben in dem man sich viel er
anfängt zu verstecken und man weiß nicht
mehr richtig wo eigentlich die
positionen sind sondern die position
werden immer immer verbogener und immer
eigenartiger und du kannst die leute gar
nicht mehr richtig verorten weil die
offenheit und das starke bild auch
teilweise eben nicht mehr gestattet ist
weil es eben schon als als als inkorrekt
gilt in vielerlei hinsicht und deswegen
glaube ich schon dass das die eine
diskussion mit der anderen diskussion
finde ich nicht wirklich nicht viel zu
tun sondern es geht darum dass wir uns
glaube ich alle einig sind wir wollen
nicht dass religion und religiosität
egal welche religion ändern
zivilrechtlichen und auch in den
sozialen rahmen hineinwächst manipulativ
sondern wir wollen dass das die religion
ein in sich 1 inso ein ein kosmos in
sich ist wo menschen etwas noch mal
leben können was andere gar nicht so
empfinden aber ohne sozusagen in den
staatlichen bereich hinein zu greifen
ich habe noch eine frage mit dem blick
mal ins ausland es gibt ja verschiedene
staaten die verschiedene andere
regelungen werden es gibt ja zum
beispiel die anglo amerikanische staat
also amerika kanada england da wird
selbst gibt es eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit dass jeder auch
religiöse symbole auch im zum beispiel
im polizeidienst tragen kann das
argument dahinter ist zum beispiel wir
stellen unsere pluralistische
gesellschaft dar und natürlich gibt es
muslimische christliche jüdische oder
sonstige religiöse menschen die auch im
polizeidienst arbeiten mache die das
eurer meinung nach alles falsch das
reden wir mal über polizei sollten wir
also sollten polizistinnen und
polizisten in deutschland religiöse
symbole tragen dürfen ja dann nein auch
keine politisch dass ich finde das echt
wichtig weil gerade die arbeit von
polizei und justiz
die auf überzeugungen fußen die sich
quasi im gegenteil von der religion
abgewendet haben das heißt england ist
auf dem holzweg ich finde das falsch wie
geht's euch nein du sagst das ist genau
richtig
der ausschuss setzt ein bis zu bald ich
sage ich wenn mein war ausschluss für
die diskriminierung findet nicht durch
das gesetz statt sondern bereits durch
den islam das heißt dadurch dass ich
meine religion ausleben es geht nicht
darum es geht es geht darum dass die
diskriminierung bereits da stattfindet
dass frauen vom islam anders behandelt
werden als männer und vor dieser die
regierung schützt sich der deutsche
straße ist richtig weiß die themen sind
miteinander verbunden werden glaube ich
aber total christentum rassismus aber
wir haben ja so unsere diversen
jahrhunderte erfahrungen mit der
religion und wir können heute nur so
frey will leben weil wir uns von der
religion emanzipiert habe ich will weder
weder dir noch die runterstellen selbst
um frei zu denken aber ich will für
verständnis dafür werben und ich stehe
hier ganz vorne dass diese die
betrachtung der religion bei
außenstehenden dazu führt dass wir nicht
den eindruck bekommen dass es sich
hierbei um eine liberale gesinnung
handelt die menschen zur
selbstbestimmung bewegt das ist das
problem stimm ich dir voll ein wenn sie
nur außen wahrnehmungen von dingen von
der legion in unseren kindern bieten
dann ist ihnen nicht geholfen sondern es
hilft ihnen exemplarisch zu zeigen wie
lebt man christ es braucht denen
wahrnehmung es braucht menschen und es
kann nicht nur lernstoff sein also ich
habe mehr und mehr das gefühl dass wir
verkennen dass es hier um
gesellschaftlichen status geht es geht
um das recht von staatsbürger ändern
ihre religionsfreiheit ausleben zu
dürfen in dem moment können sie doch
kann ich nicht nur nicht als lehrerin
nur nicht als lehrer die noch nicht als
richterin im staatsdienst
wir haben jetzt auch ein trauriges war
zirkel als kassiererin als erzieherin
wofür soll ich noch arbeiten welchem
bereich wir können uns nicht für
vielfalt und pluralität
anwältin sie dann ausschließen gerade in
staatlichen institutionen nicht wir
machen uns damit angreifbar wir können
nicht wir haben statt nicht institution
die diskriminierung schützen unsere
bevölkerung nicht davor aber ich war
müssen wir hin ich finde es irgendwie in
der interaktion mit
dritten als
personen die vom staat angestellt es
repräsentiert zu den start wenn ich
würde sehr komisch wenn wir jetzt
irgendwie für leute nachdenken die den
staat repräsentieren und deren
einschränkungen im
gesetzeslagen und ich die
schutzbedürftigen die dieser staat
vertritt und das ist glaube ich mein
problem mit dieser ganzen diskussion es
geht doch es geht auch um die schüler
erinnern es geht doch um es geht auch um
die
ich gleich wieder ein schritt zurück
gutes argument da hast du recht hat man
und das ist nicht
das stimmt schon trotzdem möchte ich
einfach noch mal sagen ich bin überzeugt
es ist kein weg dass man religion nicht
einfach ausleben und aus
ausdrücken da frei ausdrücken darf ich
glaube es gibt es gibt es führt nur zur
spaltung ich sehe die probleme die wir
alle haben aber trotzdem ist es nicht
aber ich bin ich der überzeugung es ist
nicht der weg ich glaube der weg geht so
eine kennung
zu einer echten bekennen dessen wer man
ist wir werden hier sicherlich keine
lösung finden aber ich habe das gefühl
wir haben ein paar gemeinsamkeiten schon
herausarbeiten können jetzt versuchen
wir noch mehr gemeinsamkeiten ausfällt
zu bringen wir nennen es die sogenannte
kompromiss runde ich fange mal mit was
ganz einfache mann können wir uns darauf
einigen dass eine richterin die mit
einem auffälligen kreuz durch die gegend
läuft also christin ist und das auch
zeigt trotzdem eine neutrale und gute
richterin sein kann
persönlich nicht demgegenüber gegenüber
glaubst du nicht glaubt ihr ja du wirst
mal vorne gegangen ist auch nach vorne
gegangen ist ja aber es geht ihr könnt
auch schon wesentlich wir reden aber
erstmal über die menschen die sich
vielleicht angegriffen fühlen weil sie
sauer weil sie gesagt bekommen nur weil
du ein religiöses symbol trägst glaube
ich erhalte ich dich nicht mehr für
irgendwie objektiv darum geht es mir so
jetzt geht bitte mal in euch in eure
kleinen gruppen versucht eine
formulierung zu finden wo er sagt damit
kriegen wir sie rüber ziel ist es ja
möglichst nahe zusammenzukommen kommen
um sich runde britische ich weiß es ist
schwer
aber die juristen hat eine idee also ich
zum beispiel dann öffentlich gar keinen
kollegen vorstellen ich traue es auch zu
konfigurieren was würdet ihr sagen was
wäre euer kompromissvorschlag wie kommen
diese beiden seiten noch näher zusammen
obwohl sie wahrscheinlich am ende des
tages nicht den konsens finden
vielleicht finden sie eine art
kompromiss zeigt sich dann dürfte man
aber solange sie zeigen wollte dass man
langsam zum schluss kommen bitte
insgesamt steht grün bisschen weiter
vorne als gelb also würde ich mal
vorschlagen grün fängt an damit gelb
näher zu euch kommen kann uns ist
aufgefallen dass der neutralität begriff
offensichtlich ein bisschen irritationen
hervorruft und deswegen war unsere idee
zu sagen wir verstehen die neutralität
die wir hier ein fordern die
weltanschauliche eben nicht als einen
sich raushalten oder gleichgültigkeit
oder gar als gleichgültigkeit oder gar
als tabuisierung sondern wir verlangen
dass die institutionen des staates sich
bekennen zu den werten von demokratie
und aufklärung und dann ist es für uns
angezeigt symbole die das konterkarieren
nicht vor allen dingen bei
vertreterinnen dieses staates zeigen zu
lassen ok also konnten euch die grünen
jetzt bewegen dass ihr euch bewegt nicht
wirklich der einem hilft der steuerlich
massiv und ich glaube da komme nicht
weiter
symbole konterkarieren die demokratische
freiheitliche grundordnung das ist so
ein vorurteil skela begriff der unsere
ich kann es nur von mir reden unsere
entwicklung der evangelischen kirche in
deutschland der letzten
100 jahre völlig ausblendet und da fühle
ich mich absolut nicht gesehen unser
vorschlag wäre wir gehen davon aus dass
staatliche institutionen leider auch
diskriminieren und da sind wir weil
jetzt schutzbefohlenen und wir müssen
diese menschen davor schützen wie können
wir eine lösung könnte ein landes
antidiskriminierungsgesetz sein was wir
aus berlin jetzt kennen andere burgen
das andere sind da in der diskussion
aktuell haben wir in deutschland ein
allgemeines gleichbehandlungsgesetz das
führt dazu dass man im berufsleben oder
auch von privaten nicht diskriminiert
werden darf mit der religion steht drin
so die sache ist d aber vor staatlichen
institutionen bei der abonniert von der
polizei in der schule bei der verwaltung
wenn ich da diskriminiert werde bin ich
dann nicht geschützt und warum sollte
ein staat der sich zur religionsfreiheit
und zwar des komponierens prinzipien
bekennt diese nicht auf allen
staatlichen institutionen sicherstellen
eine lösung wäre da dadurch die allein
das antidiskriminierungsgesetz und einem
bundes antidiskriminierungsgesetz um
unsere staatlichen institution zu binden
und gerade diesen schutzbefohlenen die
erde angebracht habe auch zu schützen
das ist zumindest der versuch einen
schritt auf euch zuzugeben zu sagen okay
wir sehen schutzräume braucht ist auf
eure weise wollen sie es nicht aber auf
eine andere weise quasi durch die
hintertür ein bisschen mehr tun für
schutzbedürftige menschen das ist der
vorschlag ich stehe vor allem deswegen
hier so weit vorne weil ich das habe ich
eingangs gesagt total verstehen kann
dass gerade muslime sich ungleich
behandelt fühlen gegenüber der pro
vierten christlichen religionen da war
aber dabei finde dass der staat
äquidistanz denselben abstand zu allen
religionen haben sollte und das kriegt
er am besten hin indem er den kirchen
die jetzigen privilegien wegnimmt denn
ansonsten müssten wir den islam und im
judentum die gleichen privilegien geben
wie den kirchen und das halte ich für
keine gute idee war
[Musik]
echt gedacht bei dem thema werden wir an
zwei fronten bleiben und es wird sich
nicht viel bewegt aber ich finde es war
soviel bewegungen im raum und ich haben
argumente überzeugt mich am argumente
zurück bewegt und ich fand eigentlich
richtig gute diskussionen ich fand es
gut dass wir diese möglichkeit hatten
aber an manchen stellen hatte ich schon
das gefühl dass man hier verkennt dass
es eigentlich hier um einen
gesellschaftlichen status es geht hier
auch um mein recht als ebenbürtiges
gleichwertiges mitglied in dieser
gesellschaft wahrgenommen zu merken und
das wird mir auch grad in der debatte
über den safe space hat mir das gefehlt
und ich wusste doch gar nicht wie ich
mich dazu äußern soll und wenn es gut
dass wir heute darüber diskutiert haben
dass wir auch auf augenhöhe und zu
begegnen könnten und ich glaube wir
müssen wir echt dass in den debatten
reinkriegen in der tat
muss man glaube ich noch stärker darüber
reden was die symbolik und die
eigentliche überzeugung der menschen
miteinander zu tun hat ich bin immer
noch der meinung des
institutionen schutzräume sein sollten
aber ich habe es einmal versucht
anzubringen nicht die verpackung des
kopfes
zählt in erster linie sondern der inhalt
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin
überrascht dass ihr alle relativ weit
vorne steht das habe ich vor dieser
folge nicht erwartet ich dachte im
gegenteil das viel mehr leute ganz
hinten stehen und deswegen glückwunsch
dass ihr so kompromissbereit ich finde
das ganz toll tatsächlich natürlich war
klar wir finden natürlich nicht den
einen konsens heute das ist vollkommen
logisch aber wir sind schon relativ nah
aufeinander zugegangen wahrscheinlich
mehr als es sonst der gesellschaft
passiert vielen dank dafür danke schön
danke dir danke auch an
hinter dieser diskussion und ich denke
dass heute klar geworden steckt ja vor
allem die frage in welcher gesellschaft
wollen wir leben wollen wir die religion
immer weiter zurückdrängen oder wollen
wir sie als selbstverständlichen teil
von vielen von uns in dieser
gesellschaft akzeptieren wir werden
diese frage weiter verhandeln ich gehe
davon aus auch im gerichtssaal wenn euch
13 fragen gefällt dann könnt ihr hier
unseren kanal abonnieren dort oben
findet ihr ein weiteres 13 fragen video
und hier ein weiteres video zum thema